14000 personnes y travaillent dans la
province répartis dans près de 290
entreprises les indicateurs sont clairs
le milieu québécois du jeu vidéo se
porte très bien c'est vraiment un de nos
fleurons au Québec on est dans le top 3
mondial
depuis 2020 45 nouveaux studios ont vu
le jour au Québec les entreprises
s'arrachent les talents qu'ils soient
d'ici ou d'ailleurs mais il y a quand
même encore beaucoup d'affichage de
poste donc si ça passe par oui
l'immigration la formation on est
maintenant 11 personnes à temps plein il
y a six ans Francis Lapierre au
confondit son studio de jeux vidéo il
aspire à doubler sa capacité de
production dans les années à venir
c'est ça prend du temps c'est compliqué
qu'il y a plusieurs domaines à combler
tant au niveau artistique technologique
de l'écriture des animations chaque
année il y a à peu près 1000 diplômés
qui sortent des idées collèges et
universités québécoises un nombre
insuffisant alors que les opportunités
sont grand dans l'industrie il faut
former plus de gens et les former aussi
de façon la plus adéquate possible
compte tenu des besoins très changeants
de ces industries-là
le mégamix à Montréal c'est fin de
semaine laisser j'ai pu université font
du recrutement les parents et enfants
sont nombreux
je viens m'informer je viens essayer des
jeux parler un peu à différents
compagnies que j'ai avec mon garçon
que j'ai de mon côté je trouve ça peut
être un bon moyen de nous montrer
peut-être un futur métier
à venir au pays les femmes représentées
en 2021 23% de la main d'oeuvre dans
cette industrie ça change pour le mieux
dans l'industrie puis ça passe aussi par
encourager les jeunes filles les jeunes
femmes à s'intéresser à ces métiers-là
qui mettent en lumière le dynamisme
québécois à travers le monde ici a dit
Yacine Radio-Canada Montréal